[Applause]
hi violet hi Robin um so I want to do
something to start um I don't know if
you noticed out front they're doing a
visualization of this talk did you see
that by the front door so it's pretty
excellent actually um I don't know
people in this room have seen it but
they're sort of visualizing word-count
you know so the incident of different
words like energy or space or aliens or
whatever but I think we should hack the
visualization by choosing some word and
just saying it like 50 times and I want
and I want and I want you to choose the
word you want me to chase the word yes I
get accused of using words repeatedly in
talks so I'm a little shy about doing
something like this but how about the
word conversation conversation
conversation conversation conversation
because I have some questions for you
about conversation action okay because
you are a man of your writer and you're
a man of many many hats and you have
done a lot of really interesting things
and a lot of different media forms
you've been at current you work for
Wired for a while now you're at Twitter
and so you've been involved in a lot of
conversations and as a writer you're
naturally involved in conversation so
what I want to know is with all of the
different and sort of some of the things
that you've done are a little
anarchistic because you're a little bit
of a well you say a media inventor
mm-hmm because you like to mold and
shape different types of media and
channel different ideas and thoughts
through media and I think you probably
spend a lot of time observing how these
ideas go and where they go in different
conversations so what I want to know is
how you see the arc of what you're doing
with what you've done in media how are
you or how are you interested in
changing the overall conversation in the
media that you work in okay conversation
and you don't ever say [ __ ] no if you
want to do it on macro level you could I
mean for instance like I take a look at
your over and I'm like wow this guy's an
pointer I mean a lot of really
interesting cool stuff but and now
you're at Twitter and you're like the
media dude Twitter so you're you know
you're running a blog that where you're
helping like MTV
stuff with Twitter and I'm like okay so
how does that I mean how do you see
yourself changing this larger
conversation about what these certain
garden-variety corporations can do with
the individual power of the conversation
on Twitter yeah yeah well it's a
gigantic question oh yeah I was really
wondering cuz part of me just wanted to
come up here and just go dude what are
you doing what is going I will I will
tell you there's there's a couple
different levels but all I should be
completely honest and this is actually
one of the reasons I was sort of asking
Jill about vocation and and kind of what
leads you into different things
especially in the beginning but
throughout all the things I've done I've
actually always been driven so you're
right that I like to observe and I like
to sort of your eyes and come up with
new models and things but I've always
been driven pretty fundamentally by I
don't know it's it's almost emotional
it's just the sense of what's actually
the most fun and the most fulfilling and
I think there's probably gonna be some
resonance here between us because just
as a case in point when I was first
starting out I was doing kind of this
was like 2002 2003 just when blogs were
sort of this new thing and everyone was
sort of getting excited about them and
discovering them and I was doing two
things at once I was writing traditional
articles you know long three thousand
word things they were still posted
online this wasn't even dead treats it
was still all on the web which I would
but I would sort of post these long
things with no comments just very like
here it is a perfect piece of finished
journalism for you to read and enjoy at
the same time I'd be writing blog posts
with the comments and sort of connected
to all these other things and the
difference and we're talking we on the
most basic emotional like what makes you
excited to do your work everyday level
the blog posts were blowing the
traditional stuff out of the water so
much more satisfying yeah satisfying is
the right word exactly and I mean really
it to this day I look at people who do
the other kind of stuff who sort of
create this work and then put it out
there and it's like throwing pennies
down a well and like you know you yeah
and never hearing the splash right I
don't know how they do it so
fundamentally yeah I mean but
fundamentally you know there's there's
some big ideas but it's almost it's a
little more I don't know most animal
than that just kind of like you know
what what where I've gotten positive
feedback in terms of
this is good this is fun I can do this I
can do this another day I can do this
another day as we took me to Twitter the
fact that Twitter was this kind of it
takes that feedback loop and makes it
even faster and more sort of nourishing
I guess so do you think that you were
driven by the it sounds I mean this it's
very very familiar what you're seeing
the big difference between you know old
school media and journalism presentation
regardless of all of the other factors
involved just as a writer and then
suddenly being in a position where
you're actually having a relationship
with your readers and a relationship an
ongoing relationship with the material
and also you know realizing that you're
subverting the channels of distribution
and so it sounds to me almost like I
wonder is it that conflict that drew you
into moving into alternate forms of
media and media distribution when you
say conflict you mean that sort of old
media new media divide and that's really
also seem like you've sort of intuited
your way through yes yeah intuition well
that's another great word vocation and
intuition those are both good I don't
know tags vocation vacation vacation
vacation vacation the you know I've
actually battle the sort of antagonism
has never been super appealing to me
I've always liked I've always liked the
synthesis more I mean something that I
always tell journalists I've been
telling them for a long time is that you
do the best work when you take the
values the kind of old-fashioned values
of journalism like you know honesty and
authenticity and veracity and
verification and fairness necessarily
balance but fairness and you bake those
into new stuff you can do that you can
you can use those values as effectively
in a Twitter feed as you can writing a
30,000 word piece for the New York Times
Magazine so yeah I always I always find
this sort of that the old the old versus
new like or throw down like in panels
like this right where like I'd be from a
newspaper and you'd be a blogger and
we'd like yeah exactly it's I think it's
such I think it's so boring and so not
true anyway so why bother productive so
how are you changing the conversation
with
doing a Twitter or do you see yourself
as doing that I I think so and part of
it you know it turns out that it happens
mostly there's something I've learned
actually just in the last nine months or
so working at Twitter you can make big
pronouncements and you can sort of you
know put forward big theories and you
know sort of think pieces about the
future of media but it really happens in
terms of actually making progress and
getting new work out there that is sort
of different in terms of actually doing
like media invention it totally happens
person by person it happens
sitting down I mean not not like this
but in you know a meeting or over coffee
with someone at a media company who's
sort of curious and maybe doesn't want
to admit that they're curious about this
stuff and talking it through with them
and coming up with something and maybe
it shouldn't have surprised me but the
degree to which it really is this sort
of just like person by person
organization organization organization
by organization battles not the right
word because it's again it's not a
battle it's more just uh it's a campaign
maybe like a political campaign and you
really do win it by like knocking on one
door and then knocking on the next door
and knocking on the next door so you see
it as an individualistic process or a
process that has more of an individual
or directly connected experience
involved I think so I think so and you
have to sort of take new ideas I mean if
you're talking about using Twitter you
can't just say everybody use Twitter you
have to sort of mold it into the stuff
that people are working on so if it's
MTV you sort of sort of you know you
meet them halfway talking about like big
spectacles and you talk about musicians
on Twitter and you talk about all of
their fans talking about Jersey Shore on
Twitter or whatever it is if you're
talking to the New York Times it's a
very different conversation you're
talking about news and breaking news and
you know sort of learning interesting
things about Chile's rate reaction to
the Chilean miners or whatever it is the
sort of the core idea is the same but
you have to be specific I'm I'm
increasingly skeptical of giant
overarching theory is sort of handling
everything yeah I think that's really
smart
I'm thinking of Twitter in terms of a
use case because what it is is it's it's
a just a rapid status update connect
tool essentially and there will be other
Twitter's
and what's interesting is to see the
impact of something that is an instant
status update from one individual that
grows like a spore and moves and of
course you know all the exciting data
mining and graphing that goes along with
you know seeing how news stories are
told and how news stories are are
sourced increasingly through this type
of a communication model and I'm
wondering how you see these individually
driven or people I mean it's it
eventually becomes crowdsourcing but it
all starts with an individual or -
changing what happens with news media
well I want so I'll tell you one thing
that's really important but I want to
sort of connect it back around to you
what's that I completely geek out in
news media absolutely
um media in general so the one thing
that's super interesting to me I've had
this on the brain just because I've been
reading about this a lot recently and
also cuz we were talking earlier some
there were conversations about things
like lenses and pictures of far-off
planets and telescopes and things like
that I think one of the really quiet
revolutions names known as quite as I
think it is but one of the sort of
things that has snuck up on us is that
everybody is a photographer all the time
like the way photography fits into our
lives is so weird now I mean if you just
think about the way people thought about
cameras or taking pictures even four
years ago it's completely different now
so obviously that has huge almost
unimaginable implications for news when
suddenly we can something happens and
you sort of capture it from 95 different
angles and you can find ways to sort of
synthesize that I mean there's there's
no question this is already happening
but there's just no question that the
signature images of big events are
increasingly gonna come from sort of
people's cell phones or whatever they
end up being being called sort of there
on the scene but it changes more than
just news right I mean this changes the
way we think about ourselves and
communicating with people and I think it
probably changes sex too or changes
relationships and I'm curious when you
think because I know that's something
that you spend a lot of time thinking
about and writing about and talking
about
maybe wants to view time but photography
what's I mean I don't know enough about
the overall sort of context over not
just the last five years the last 20
years or the last hundred years but when
you think about phones and maybe Twitter
and photography how does this how does
this kind of change things is it
changing things in terms of sexuality
yeah and the way we express ourselves
sexually the way we sort of just the
whole sort of culture of sex it's
changed almost every aspect of sexuality
absolutely I mean and we're talking in
Western nations certainly where we're
free to do this and it's it's changed
the idea of self because we're given
much more of a mirror and much more of
an accurate mirror of taking a look at
ourselves and when we can control a
little more right I'm sort of it well
I'm sorry I said I always feel like
we've all become masters of self
portraiture now maybe I'm I I don't
think that I think that there's a lot of
myth around how much control you have
when you take pictures of yourself and
what you do with them or pictures of
other people and what you do with them
online I think that what what I think is
particularly interesting about the way
that pictures and the ability of
everyone to take pictures has changed
sexuality is that it's been part of the
gigantic disruption of the porn
distribution complex and what it's
allowed people to do is to start to make
their own pornography and show
themselves and start to show what they
actually really want to see and show a
much more realistic and I think
healthier picture of human sexuality
rather than the mass-produced
stereotypes that we have been accustomed
to seeing for decades after decades or
having to go source out secretly which
then maybe didn't also present a very
healthy portrait of sexuality so I think
that overall it's a disruption that's
incredibly incredibly good overall
culturally I think it's incredibly
empowering especially for women because
it's allowed women to take control of
their image back to themselves not just
in the way they present themselves and
saying hey my unenhanced body is
actually really hot and here's a whole
bunch of people that think so but also
in that in order to get distribution if
a woman wants to monetize her image she
doesn't need to go to a man and have him
do so
thing to help her monetize it or give
her money to anyone else so it's also
eliminating a lot of the myths and the
stereotypes of women doing things
because they're being coerced in a
sexual context women being less
empowered around their own sexuality and
having less control of it and also women
needing to go to men I mean it's it's a
heteronormative assumption of Morris
because binary but it's it's actually
you know that and the media distribution
disruption that we've been you know
excitedly surfing at least you and I
have for the past ten years I think it's
huge and I think it's incredibly healthy
let's let's let's zoom it out a little
more just because this is a long now and
sort of long term thinking event because
I'm thinking now back in terms of news I
think there might actually be some
interesting surprising parallels here so
in terms of news so of course the the
most recent thing of the last five years
is this democratization of this sort of
image production but really the fact
that news is largely visual is itself a
pretty new thing I mean yeah it's it's
fun I don't if you ever done it to go
back and look at old old old newspapers
and they're just like all texts and sort
of like a woodcut drawing in the corner
and you realize that the news it was it
was your imagination you like you didn't
maybe even know what the president
really looked like I mean that's
interesting so so with news we've seen
that we've seen this rise of sort of the
image and and especially for people who
read a lot and I sort of always online
consuming words I think it's easy to
forget that most people sort of get
their news and process news really
visually I mean it really is sort of
salient images and sort of clips of
video and people on a TV screen I don't
know how much of it in Western cultures
what do you mean well in a lot of I've
recently been doing a little bit of
research about non-western cultures an
open Internet access and access to to
news and media and culture and not a lot
of the world has access to an open
Internet you know they don't have access
to YouTube they don't have access to to
you know the upper classes certainly do
but by and large a lot of very large
nations don't have access to this type
of news but they still have TV right and
TV is I mean for as much as we talk
about the
internet TV is still unless it's
state-controlled but even then but even
then so the sore the provenance of the
images is sort of questionable but still
images you still get it through images
but continue but so to connect it to
connect it back around and I don't know
how much of a historian of sex you are
if you kind of like zoom way out and
look at the last few hundred years or
even like the last thousand years does
that just just the rise of images you
know photography video does that change
things what what did sex even in the
culture of sex look like before it was
easy to you know mass produce and
distribute images before the mass
distribution of images well I think that
for those who are sighted I think that
inherently sex is a very visual thing
anyway because sex if you're not looking
at the act as you do it I would say nine
times out of ten most people have a
running fantasy in their head of either
what they're doing or what they're
thinking of or something else because
sex is so reliant on fantasy and because
the majority of amount of the amount of
sex that most people have is
masturbation and that is a very fantasy
reliant thing so it's a matter of are
you talking about images that you're
running in your head as a team or images
that we're sort of you know finding in a
mass-produced way I mean sure you could
say oh well there were two Rocco types
there were you know you could go you
know the guys could go and watch a
smoker with their buddies house if they
had a stag film or something like that
and now it's you know it's it's 4chan
it's it's you know it's just like go
wherever you want you don't find things
that you want to that make you want to
take your brain out and put it in a pile
of bleach and you know wish you never
saw it but you can also find a lot of
things that are what you've always
imagined and often times enacted by
professionals in safe contexts so I
don't think that I don't know that we
haven't ever been a sexually visual
culture it's interesting one interesting
thing a good Psychology Today article
about the power of fantasy and
masturbation are really important images
I mean I would actually love to I would
love to know and it might just be a
question that's impossible to answer how
much because it's feedback loops right I
think a lot about feedback loops and the
way that was work and seeing movies
changes the way that we visualize things
you know before there were movies I I
would love to know I'd love to be able
to do that I think it's just impossible
to kind of you know know or hear
described how people visualize things
like what that the minds movie camera
see even our even that we can't get away
from it the vocabulary we talk about the
minds movie camera or you said you said
the tape in your mind which I love
because of course we don't even use tape
but we still and you you see these great
layers there's no tape there was never
any tape I love that stuff that's not
that's another I will say that's another
reason back to your original question
why do I like this stuff I like it
because it doesn't just sort of sit out
here it affects us you know stories and
different kinds of media give them a
little time and they actually kind of
change our brains and what it means to
be human too I think it's pretty cool in
a better way I think so I'm an optimist
I actually think so I think I think all
of this stuff synthesizing together kind
of stewing in this big pot I think the
soup gets teased to you over time
but other people might disagree it's
definitely different and that's at least
always interesting yes evolution
conversation conversation conversation
conversation conversation conversation a
pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you